are you sick of show business in a way
and i'll tell you why you've been doing
it since you're a little kid it is a
tremendous struggle to keep finding good
projects and to keep your name out there
and then you host the emmys and you host
the oscars and then you host this and
that and then you say every day well
what the [ __ ] am i doing all this for
have you ever had that moment of doubt
about the career choice
of just the entertainment industry
that's right no no you love it
i started it so young man i was i was 12
turning 13 when i started it that it
sort of has has been all i've known what
did you got the white goldberg movie was
that how when you started yeah
unbelievable first audition kind of
thing yeah and you got the whoopi
goldberg movie i did what was the name
of that movie clara's heart and you were
a little kid you've went on an audition
for whoopi goldberg's movie
and then you're working with whoopi
goldberg your family must have been
floored right yeah it was it was just so
surreal and outside of the normal world
you still in touch with her yeah
sometimes yeah but you're not super
close as a result of that no but when we
see each other it's we have like an
extra special moment and hug and stuff
because does she think of you as like a
kid like or like hey i started with i
started this kid out or something is
there some sort of special uh bonding
kind of thing i don't know about from
her point of view but from my point of
view it's i'm i always feel a special
bond to her because she was a big giant
movie star and i got to star in a movie
i think it's amazing it's my first time
because i always think of your story i
tell people this all the time neil was
at acting camp and then right out of
acting camp he auditioned for whoopi
goldberg and got the got the part in our
movie what's it like after you make a
movie with whoopi goldberg and then you
go back to high school is it [ __ ]
weird is everyone like uh kissing your
ass all of a sudden are you now a
superstar at school no it was more it
was more that you were weird and kind of
more of an outcast yeah because really
yeah well i lived in a small town in new
mexico called ruidoso ski resort town
right and when i went and did the movie
i came back for just a little bit and
then we moved to albuquerque so i became
suddenly the new kid in a new school in
a new town and you wouldn't really have
to deal with that but you weren't the
new kid who's in the movies well there
was a bigger school in albuquerque and
so there was a proper theater department
so i was able to become friends with
actor with like you know other theater
geek when you go to school in
albuquerque
uh and you've done a movie and then you
try out for the school play are you like
[ __ ] you [ __ ] i was in a [ __ ]
movie why am i auditioning why am i
going to be the player i should be
directing no really to be honest i
struggled i i yearned i yearned for
normalcy did you yeah you are a normal
guy but i i was in such a weird
environment and doing so many weird
things and i was from new mexico and
then i was suddenly
at the golden globes right around
celebrity people and i didn't feel like
i fit in at all and then when you're at
that age you just want to have friends
and be kind of a normal person just in
life even if you aren't doing anything
you